just pick up on that line that the
government will now ban russian aircraft
from coming in what does that actually
mean
yeah we've already had a ban of course
on uh russian aircrafts as in aeroflot
the state-owned company and even private
jets or other commercial aircraft what
we're doing now is is going further
we've taken some additional
laws i i
powers rather i signed the law late last
night which actually means we'll be able
to be more specific and for example
where we have uh aircraft which might be
connected with russian oligarchs
flying into the country they should know
this sends the clearest signal of all uh
you can't do that anymore we can impound
your uh aircraft it turns this into a
criminal uh offense and i hope uh sets
out this position very very clearly to
them
yeah i mean
we're talking a lot about uh aircraft
this morning aren't we mr shap so
peasant zelinski of course wants the uk
to protect ukrainians guys we've had
this discussion overnight about polish
jets being used by the ukrainian air
force where are we with that because it
seems to be a bit of confusion the u.s
saying that that idea of poland loaning
its mix to the ukrainian air force is
untenable
yeah look i mean actually poland's in
nato we all work to together on this uh
and uh it's important um i think that we
uh are a defensive uh organization uh
which means that uh we won't be getting
directly involved in the uh war uh i i
as you rightly say uh the united states
has said that it won't be taking those
uh mig jets that only fly uh make jets
themselves um so that's not uh that's
not something which is going to develop
but make no mistake we're providing huge
amounts of aid and support at the united
kingdom as the first country to provide
anti-tank uh weaponry before this uh war
broke out before ukraine was attacked as
well as training 22 000 ukrainian troops
which is something else the united
kingdom did so we stand fully behind uh
ukraine we heard from president um
yesterday in parliament in that
remarkable speech that zelinski gave
with echoes of churchill and we are
doing everything that we possibly can to
support uh our ukrainian friends
yeah so you're saying now that the
british government doesn't support the
idea of poland loaning its migs to the
ukrainian air force
i should say it was nothing to do with
the um british government this is
between
of course we are sorry
of course of course not but as you
mentioned we are part of the nato
alliance and you know that yesterday on
this program the defense secretary said
that it would be entirely up to poland
if they wanted to loan their jets to
ukraine poland say they will loan those
jets so where's the uk government stand
it's we're not involved in this
particular loan uh idea and the
americans have said that they will not
proceed in that manner
and look i think let me just be
completely up front view
we need to make sure that in
our
absolutely stringent support for uh
ukraine who are not a nato member of
course we are not inadvertently doing
something uh which escalates uh this war
uh in a way that uh would be uh
unacceptable um to the entire world and
so we're being of course rightly
careful and cautious providing huge
amounts of humanitarian aid providing a
military support as well as you already
heard but not involving ourselves
directly in the fighting and i think
that is absolutely the right stance
and some may say not providing adequate
refugee support i mean you've seen the
numbers mr shaps you've seen that some
500 visas have been uh accepted 500
visas accepted no idea how many
ukrainians have actually come here
it's shameful isn't it the way that the
uk has held handled this refugee crisis
in europe
760 uh granted now of 22 000
applications which are on their way
through
look i don't agree with you no country
has given more humanitarian assistance
to ukraine than the united kingdom in
the world we've given 400 million pounds
in addition the british people have been
incredibly generous as well uh
geographically we are of course spaced
further to the west and president
zielinski and the ukrainian government
have told me that they do not want
people to move far away uh if at all
possible in the country because they
want people to be able to uh come back
having said that we have uh two schemes
uh one of which allows up to two hundred
000 ukrainians here that's the extended
family scheme and it does extend to all
parts of somebody's family aunts and
uncles and that sort of thing
and then of course we've also announced
a a sponsorship route again for those
people without family ties and unlimited
so you know we are we are really leaning
into this at the same time respecting uh
ukraine's wishes the government's wishes
uh not to pull people a long way away
from ukraine which is not something that
they want to see happen but as ever
showing the the the british generosity
particularly in humanitarian support uh
as the largest donor nation
absolutely right lots of money has been
given and lots of people are giving up
uh things for ukrainians but the
geographical thing doesn't quite work
when ireland's taken some 2 000 people
and people in calais are stuck at the
border unable to come in
i think it's right that uh and people
would expect us to uh be wanting to
check people's status before they come
in we know that russia
are uh
involved in all sorts of um uh uh
all manner of operations so it's
absolutely right to check that
somebody's come from ukraine and know
who is coming to this country um
essentially uh and uh and and that's
what we're doing but we will you know
undoubtedly have a lot of uh ukrainians
come here uh to seek refuge they'll be
incredibly welcomed by uh the population
by the local authorities by the uh
government we've shown that huge
generosity this country i mean most
people probably don't realize that over
a hundred thousand for example hong kong
chinese have taken up uh their right of
of uh citizenship that we've granted 25
000 from syria this country has always
been incredibly um generous but as i
said i do want to stress president
zielinski has asked us to proceed in the
way that we are are doing i i do agree
with you the need to make sure that
there are sufficient place people to be
able to uh access that visa support uh
an office in lille has just been set up
uh paris is available i checked last
night uh there are appointments
available uh for people who are making
their way west uh but as i say we we we
are no country uh out forms the united
kingdom when it comes to humanitarian
assistance at 400 million and no other
country has provided more of that
assistance so we really can be proud of
what we're doing on the ground and it
it's help that the ukrainians are
specifically asking us to provide as
well yeah i mean on that mr shouts did
the home secretary preach patel mislead
parliament when she said that there was
a visa center set up in calais he said
it twice and there isn't one
so there's visa assistance in in calais
i know so there are there are british
officials
where you can take biometrics and
those kind of details that are necessary
if people to pass the visa requirements
to get into the country
yeah look i i didn't hit the specific
comment but i do know that in little uh
there is a center being set up uh i do
also know that because of the nature of
the situation in calais of course very
long-term uh issues there of um criminal
gangs bringing people across we're very
keen to separate these two issues so
that people don't get involved or caught
up
in some of that and on their way towards
the united kingdom if they're coming
here particularly for those family
schemes or later for the sponsorship
schemes we want to make sure that people
can have been uh processed via the visa
application centers we've got 6 000 it
has been massively expanded usually the
i think about 800 slots would be
available we've got 6 000 slots
available uh now for people um who are
seeking those um visas uh and uh you
know i think it's very important that
britain does throw its arms around and
try to assist but i do want to stress
that president zielenski has directly
asked us uh for the humanitarian
provision and doesn't want people
broadly speaking unless they have those
family ties but broadly speaking would
prefer people to settle uh closer uh to
ukraine because we want people he wants
people uh to go back again uh which is
very important when it comes to
rebuilding this country and post-war
no absolutely right we will listen to
what president zelinski has to say
because of course you don't want people
close by to the country but you said you
didn't hear the home soaks yesterday
i'll tell you what she said she said
that there's a visa center set up in
calais uh sarajegal says that that's not
true and if you've lied to parliament
it's a resigning matter do you
agree i don't know i i i
didn't hear the comments although except
what you're saying to me uh i do know
there's a century yeah sure i do know
there's a visa center in in lille
and i know that there are a number of
centers as people travel uh west there
are also people assisting in calais in
order to help provide people with
direction and information i do just
stress that point that what we don't
want to do is see people fleeing ukraine
caught up with what is we know very much
is a you know criminal people
trafficking uh operation that runs out
of calais uh which is something we
certainly don't want people escaping war
to then get caught up in so what we
encourage everybody to do
is to use one of the 24-hour uh phone
numbers uh arrange for the uh for to see
what to see somebody through one of
those 6 000 now uh visa appointments
which were available uh and
and take up one of the routes as i say
we've got very very i've seen this
reported a lot and it's slightly
mystifying we've got very very generous
uh program in place and further programs
coming along the program for the
extended family for example could see
200 thousand ukrainians come here the
sponsorship scheme again will be uh
unlimited uh when that's when that's
launched and uh you know i think i think
it's uh you know tribute to the british
people the amount of uh help and
assistance that people have been giving
and this country has provided more
humanitarian support by the government
plus in addition to what people have
private being given than any other
country okay mr jackson finally then
quickly if you can please uh appreciate
all of that but some people will say
that they need more help to get to this
country but we'll move on quickly to the
news overnight that the uk us i knew you
were going to phase out the use of
russian oil and gas where's the uk going
to get its energy from if it stops using
russian surprises
i should point out the uk doesn't buy
for example petrol none of our petrol
comes from um russia we do have some um
some some gas and some uh diesel uh as
you point out look
my view is quite simple we we need to
stem the flow of putin's gas and oil
blood money from funding his war machine
and i think that the british people
even
though it will of course lead to some
higher energy prices although we've
probably already seen
that as a that happening already the
british people are not prepared to see
us funding uh putin's horrific war and
so i think it's very very important that
we um take this step uh we will step up
our own production and we're fortunate
in the uk that we don't buy
proportionately very much russian oil
and gas and we do also produce our own
so we'll step that up as well but i
think it's incredibly important that we
do this because we must not be providing
the blood money to fund his war mr shabs
okay grant shabs uk transportation thank
you very much for your time thank you
thank you